[Music]
welcome to season 16 lady it's our sweet
16 you believe it yeah
this season you will be working with
models of all sizes these girls they
have curves and butts and hips and all
kinds of good stuff
oh did you ever think you find
yourselves in a boxing ring the coldest
place in Manhattan right with sandwiches
for everyone
unconventional materials challenge we
definitely understand how hard this must
be all of us Wow he did amazing and now
I guest judge for today
Demi Lovato dove Cameron Olivia Munn
Kate Upton China and McClain Kelsea
Ballerini Katie Holmes Maddie Ziegler
Yolanda Hadid and Asia Kate Williams the
way that it was done I do not agree with
Michael why are you running at this
stage this has never happened in the
history of the show I came to play fair
and there is no fairness in this game
what happened I have no idea for
somebody needs to explain
this is cheating it all has to stop this
entire thing and disgusts me
it was unprofessional unseemly atrocious
[Music]